do you think the dallas cowboys have a
chance this season i'm not much of a
basketball fan
football where are you from providence
oh [ __ ]
okay um so what's your favorite thing
about
uh lobster or uh
what do you guys eat chowder uh like
chowder i got hit by a car fell off a
roof hit by another car
jesus chris were you in the movie fast
and furious
i got peripheral nerve damage and memory
problems
do you remember who i am no you didn't
tell me who you were though
oh yeah i'm riley i'm will nice to meet
you nice to meet you
you are kind of like batman why you're
out in the night
you're you're appeasing the citizens
uh what is your uh
do you uh have anything you want to say
to the kids out there
do more drugs new drugs
that aren't drugs as drugs experiment
that's it and that's a word of advice
of the day hey what's up dan hi hello
hi what's your name oh
that was just in your nose yeah you want
to touch it yes
oh god here we go and
you look like a millennial santa claus
i am dude hey you know i'm coming for
all the ho ho ho's you know what i mean
[ __ ]
hey kobet's over you know
get vaccinated or maybe don't it all
depends on you though are you vaccinated
i mean [ __ ]
i ain't gonna say nothing we mexican out
here we from mexico
who's we me hi
what religion are you guys i'm christian
christian kristen why do you care uh i
don't i don't care at all
uh taco bell live
talk about live quesalupa
wow can you just say that to the camera
i really like casey loopas
can you put case loopers on the delivery
menu they don't have them on doordash
and it makes me really sad sometimes
you know i really you know talk about
stuff but there could be some
improvements
i don't i don't know what else to talk
about besides chicago do you have
anything you want to say the kids
[ __ ] them kids yeah [ __ ] them how do you
guys feel about russia
wait what's up how do you feel about
russia russia
look russia is well i'm obviously
pro-communism but i'm anti-russia
what was that i recognized your friend
who's a comedian
you look like a librarian
this guy's a trump boater i'm a biden
boater
and the big thing is that we're uniting
tonight over the fact that like
we need to crush china we need to crush
russia
but more importantly we need to crush
[ __ ] i think the zeitgeist
would confirm what we're saying is this
going on to the google or the youtube
i can't jam my [ __ ] into another [ __ ]
hello wonderful people how have you been
tonight
hello welcome to 6th street how have you
been tonight
we're so good now you're twins we're
twins
by how much one minute one minute
congratulations how do you feel about
this victory i feel very good
very good would anyone like to uh
make out with me
oh one kiss okay one kiss
oh yeah let's go
[Applause]
right color shot do you have nothing
that's it that's it i already had you
better put that on your youtube channel
okay
oh it's going on there on my highlight
reel for life
no problem i can say hey you surf
do i what do you surf on the turf surf
on the turf
yes yes yes mahala
mahalo what are you talking about i'm
talking about surfing
no i don't serve
good night thank you i kissed the girl
and i liked it what do you think about
the
current crisis in uh sixth street [ __ ]
do you guys like cocaine yes
i'm at work bro okay
i'm at work though i'm working right now
you got to go sorry about that
you're good man i like weed yes
what is your motivation
my motivation
my motivation is a set of
different beneficial repercussions that
are a factor of what i do
what do you do it depends on whatever my
goal is
so that makes sense yes
i like receiving head that's my favorite
straight up yes do you like uh yeah
huh do you like that wow that's
kind of sexually charged [ __ ] the
vaccine [ __ ] the vaccine why
i don't trust that [ __ ] vaccination
because i've had coronavirus foreign
times go to arizona state
sun devils let's go how many times have
you had chlamydia
only seven times perversion her dad is
gay knows all about stds and [ __ ] yeah i
come inside
his entire friend group is seeing my
dick besides him
too all right let's go
hey what up are you a rapper hell yeah
they call me lil ryan
let's hear a freestyle they call me
little ryan i don't give no [ __ ]
got a camera i can't rap i'm kidding
dude do drugs
hell yeah i like molly i got acid
marijuana but then i started worshiping
the devil hey what do you guys have to
say to joe biden
what do you have to say to joe biden joe
biden babe you need to get a grip like
get it together let's go
pick up the pace come on you got it
people usually ask me what i'm
on i i usually say my name
okay what is your name mason phx
i didn't go to high school you went to
college but not in high school
i just skipped right over it you see
you're really smart
no just you just get lucky sometimes and
they let you skip
don't do drugs kids don't not do drugs
do you support marijuana legalization i
do
i do uh are you doing anything to
make that happen um i joined this
organization
which one ut org that supports marijuana
you know so is that just
people smoking weed something like that
i have to say to joe biden
have you ever seen an abortion yeah
when live yeah
what's it to you what do you have to say
to the kids out there
um grow up rebel against your government
become a bolshevik that's what i say are
you gonna overthrow the government
i mean that's the goal what do you get
how are you gonna do it
i'm gonna do it with an organized
socialist party
i think you would really like my friend
hans probably
what was that that's what that was
was that your signature sound that was
my
can you do it again once more for the
camera
i'll do it three times for you do it
[Music]
we found the phone
are you guys scooby doo i am not but
do you guys want to get a narnia i would
be [ __ ] uh we're doing a thing for
taco bell live
just taco taco [ __ ] never heard of it
your setup is pretty basic if it's taco
bell
i mean they can't slide you some more
corporate money i'm disappointed in taco
bell is what i'm saying what's your
favorite uh pronoun
i don't think i have a favorite it's
just generic you know they're
descriptive
i mean they're case by case you have
anything you want to say to joe biden
yes stop sending money to [ __ ] israel
free palestine [ __ ] so what don't you
like about jews
what's your favorite map that's kind of
hard i guess
i mean what kind of question
is that what do you think is the point
of life
what do you want to extend how do you my
dick
uh he apparently extended his dick
towards me so what's your favorite porn
i don't know i like black people
sweet awesome what is the best quality a
ceo can have today
everything a boss [ __ ] what your name
is
hans kim comedy oh lord jesus well my
name
is zora what is the most crunchest way
to get drunk tonight i have no idea
do you guys love to party uh they do
were you guys all fishermen on a vest
vessel that got stranded and you guys
became brothers
no yeah definitely not he's working for
himself
he's homeless no i wouldn't say that
although he looks a little bit homeless
yeah free spirit just loving people and
trying to destroy capitalism
yes yes how is that what is the best way
to destroy you guys
oh how you guys are my allies how what
is the best way to destroy capitalism
any message to the texans here in uh the
great state of texas
and our freedoms and our guns oh [ __ ]
oh my god go
texas hans is sucking me into the vortex
of his own kind of
low-key despondency yeah why why would
anyone be like that i'm having a great
time man
let's just keep the energy artificially
high that's not what i well maybe it's
artificially high
but that's maybe just how i am not
naturally you know you're naturally
artificially high
yeah i mean naturally always the natural
chemicals making me artificially high
all right well take it easy